also nach den aktuellen Aussagen von
Karl Lauterbach muss die kurve-impfung
nun endgültig gestoppt werden ganz
einfach warum die von Karl Lauterbach
genannten Zahlen geben wirklich Grund
zur Sorge er gibt dir an dass ungefähr
bei rund wenn man das jetzt nachrechnet
was er gesagt hat er rund 20.000 schwere
Fälle von Nebenwirkungen vorliegen und
einfach mal ins Verhältnis zu setzen und
jetzt bitte nicht gleich aufsteigen wenn
es das Wort konnte gar nicht in den Mund
nehmen aber man muss sich einfach mal
überlegen als wir konnten als das war
waren das 3000 Fälle in Deutschland nun
gehen wir von ungefähr 20.000 Fällen
oder von schweren nebenwirkungsfällen
aus laut Karl Lauterbach
der Karl Lauterbach hat leider Gottes
das Vertrauen der Bevölkerung und auch
der Institutionen hier in Deutschland
stark beschädigt und das ist RKI die
Sticker und natürlich das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium und er
behauptet weiterhin und hat Unwahrheiten
behauptet bezüglich der Impfung und hat
somit natürlich die Gefährlichkeit die
der Impfung verharmlost und deshalb ist
ganz klar mein Fazit und mein Appell an
Herrn Lauterbach heute und hier bitte
treten Sie zurück übernehmen sie
Verantwortung und entschuldigen Sie sich
bei den Bürgern das heute ihr Appell wir
haben das Interview mit Karl Lauterbach
gesehen das hat für viel Aufregung
gesorgt in dieser Woche was stellt sie
an diesem Interview an dieser Kehrtwende
besonders uns sie haben auch starke
Zweifel haben sie gerade dargelegt an
den Zahlen die der Gesundheitsminister
da genannt hat
alles an dem Interview weiß hin und
vorne nicht echt ist da er Lauterbach
der benutzt die sogenannte Salamitaktik
er gibt nur das zuerst das ein ähm was
nun bekannt ist jetzt liegen die Karten
auf dem Tisch es zeigt sich
regelmäßig dass die Impfschäden doch
höher liegen als man eigentlich
ursprünglich angenommen hat und nun
endlich
liegt er das in einem Interview da und
und möchte dann auch noch irgendwas
gründen und den Menschen zu helfen er
ist tief betroffen er findet es ganz
schrecklich er sagt aber auch all die
Zeit hatte über die Zahlen Bescheid
gewusst also ich z.B weiß nicht wie
jetzt auf die Zahl 1 10.000 kommt man
kann einmal den Preis
sicherheitsberichten nachlesen durch
Verdachtsmeldungen drin und es werden
drei
von 10.000 aber wenn der Lauterbach als
Gesundheitsminister sagt es sind eins zu
zehntausend dann muss man davon ausgehen
dass er da Kenntnis hat und
das ist viel wenn man sich das
hochrechnet an den verimpften
Einzeldosen dann sind es rund 20.000
Menschen und das ganze Interview galt
einfach nur in meinen Augen einer
Vorbereitung dass der Bürger jetzt
langsam aber sicher darauf hin
getrimmt werden soll auf die auf die
schreckliche Botschaft das immer mehr
Impfschäden kommen werden sie gerade
paul Ehrlich Institut muss ich hier noch
einmal werden
sie das hören sie haben auch das
Interview gesehen mit dem
Gesundheitsminister das ist eine ganz
schöne kehrt wenn jetzt sind die Sorgen
sehr groß und auch die Frage Zeichen
dahinter warum heißt es erst
nebenwirkungsfrei und jetzt dieses
Eingeständnis hier ist von Salami die
rede ja der Karl Lauterbach hat das
Thema völlig unterschätzt und hat die
Sorgen die ja auch schon vor einiger
Zeit da waren überhaupt nicht ernst
genommen sondern beiseite gewischt
teilweise ja noch sogar Sprüche gemacht
in Richtung derjenigen die
Ängste und Sorge haben die ich auch
völlig inakzeptabel empfunden habe und
da gilt wirklich einiges aufzuarbeiten
das beste Mittel um eine Änderung im
Gesundheitsministerium herbeizuführen
ist CDU zu wählen denn wir hätten eine
Alternativen ja oh Gott bitte das ist
eine also
die beste Alternative wäre wenn
Institutionen frei werden
ja ohne irgendeine politischen
Schnickschnack ohne dass er
Gesundheitsminister irgendwo sitzt und
dem RKI der sticko oder die mit dem Pie
in irgendeiner Art und Weise vorsteht
diese Institutionen müssen frei und
unabhängig sein denn das RKI der
rki-chef dient dem Gesundheitsminister
das ist relativ einfach ist die
Systematik im behördenwesen und deshalb
ist es vollkommen egal wer dorthin setz
dich mal hinterher sparende Vorgänger
vom Herr Lauterbach wenn ich in den arg
enttäuscht ich glaube der war bei der
CDU oder ist noch bei der CDU sehe ich
das richtig schon Paare touristische
Frage also bitte der hat diese Verträge
abgeschlossen mit den Pharmafirmen er
hat sie von der Haftung entlassen
beteiligen weil das ist in der Zeit
geschehen als alle gesagt haben wir
brauchen dringend mehr Impfstoff nein
das ist nicht richtig das haben nicht
nein
sagen wir mal so an die Experten dann
haben sie recht wenn sie sagen die
Experten die gehört werden wollten von
der Bundesregierung nein ja sondern es
ist so es gab es gab eine sehr sehr
große Mehrheit im Land wenn man sich
damals an die Diskussion erinnert auch
die Bild-Zeitung hat gesagt endlich
brauchen wir den impfturbo und die im
Schnecke die muss dringend mehr
Impfstoffe bekommen also Deutschland
wurde als im Schnecke bezeichnet und es
gab von ganz ganz vielen Seiten die
Forderung endlich mehr Impfstoffe zu
beschaffen und da auch pragmatisch zu
handeln und wenn man jetzt paar Jahre
später sagt er damals hätte man so
machen sollen und so ich bin völlig
dafür auch aus dieser Zeit zu lernen und
zu analysieren was muss in Zukunft
besser laufen aber man macht sich auch
ein bisschen einfach wenn man jetzt sagt
also ich wusste alles schon besser und
die haben damals den Fehler gemacht und
da da wurde unter Hochdruck gehandelt
man musste in teilweise Stundentakt
enorm wichtige Entscheidung fällt und
natürlich würde man zwei drei Jahre
später manches anders machen aber jetzt
zu sagen also Jens Spahn der hat da
alles falsch gemacht da muss ich
wirklich widersprechen
in den vollkommen zu das war
außergewöhnliche Situation aber man hat
den Fehler gemacht man hat nicht auf die
Kritiker gehört und da werden sie mir
doch ganz sicher Recht geben die Frau
Merkel und nach der Herr Spanien die
haben sich genau diese Experten Kohlen
die das Lied von denen gesungen haben
das war so ein andere Kritiker die
einfach mal gesagt haben bitte langsam
egal um welche Maßnahmen sind in der
corona-pandemie gab die wurden schlicht
und ergreifen nicht gehört und wurden
sie mal ganz kurz gehört dann wurden sie
anschließend niedergemacht ja
auf die Kritiker da also Sie haben ja
für eine Impfpflicht plädiert würden sie
das jetzt anders sehen ich habe nicht
gesagt wir brauchen grundsätzlich eine
Impfpflicht hat gesagt ja ich habe ich
habe im Bundestag ich wir haben damals
gesagt wir brauchen eine Sondersitzung
darüber zu entscheiden und das zu
debattieren weil das damals ja eine sehr
dringende Debatte im ganzen Land war
aber ich habe gesagt in der damaligen
Zeit heute finde ich ist eine
Impfpflicht überhaupt nicht angemessen
der damaligen Zeit wenn wir
sicherstellen können dass mit einer
Impfpflicht ist keine weiteren lockdowns
gibt die ja enorme Kollateralschäden
verursacht haben dann gibt es Argumente
für eine Impfpflicht aber natürlich ist
das ein Mittel was man wirklich nur in
ganz extremen Situation heranziehen kann
aber ich will noch mal ganz kurz die
Frage beantworten weil das in der Tat
sehr sehr spannend ist und ich bin
völlig frei davon zu sagen also wir als
CDU oder die verantwortlichen Politiker
die haben immer alles richtig gemacht
natürlich mit heutigen Wissen würde mal
einiges anders machen
oder absolut richtig damals war das für
mich persönlich auch noch kein Thema und
wie konntest das ist ja aber ich will
ganz kurz die Frage einmal beantworten
also wir hatten zu Beginn der
corona-krise gab es von 95 Prozent der
Menschen im Land gibt ja repräsentative
Umfragen die Forderung harte lockdowns
einzuführen da gab es eher die Kritik
man habe nicht schnell genug reagiert
man hätte noch härter reagieren müssen
war wirklich auch von ganz vielen Medien
inklusive der Bild-Zeitung überall
gefordert worden und irgendwann hat sich
das natürlich umgedreht und die
entscheidende Frage war immer wann
bekommt man den Wechsel hin also von den
lockdowns die am Anfang berechtigt waren
wieder hin zu einer liberalen oder wenn
man so will normalen Gesellschaft und
genau diesen Moment zu erwischen das ist
nicht so einfach und natürlich weiß man
im Nachhinein immer besser wann ist der
geeignete Moment worauf hätte man achten
sollen jetzt in der Bundeswehr
beispielsweise gilt weiterhin die
Impfpflicht würden sie das jetzt heute
stand jetzt mit dem Wissen jetzt sofort
ich bin ich bin nicht mehr für eine im
Moment halte ich das nicht für notwendig
hat sich bei ihre Sicht auf die
Maßnahmen verändert im Zuge der Pandemie
mit dem Wissen stand jetzt heute
eigentlich eigentlich nicht ich habe der
ganzen Sache schon von der Anfang an so
ein bisschen
kritisch gegenüber gestanden weil ich
einfach vieles ich übertrieben fand ich
konnte natürlich auch manches gar nicht
beurteilen wir sinnvoll ist aber mich
hat vor allem gestört dieser ungemeine
Druck der aufgebaut wurde und wenn sie
jetzt sogar sagen dieser Druck war sogar
für die Politik handlungsleiten dann
finde ich das alarmierend weil ich
möchte nicht dass solche Maßnahmen wie
das junge gesunde Männer wie z.B der
Fußballer wie hieß
der vorgeführt wurde also an seiner
Stelle jungen gesund Spitzensportler an
seiner Stelle hätte ich mich auch
gefragt ob ich mich mit so einem
Impfstoff der vielleicht ältere wirklich
schützt und für die sinnvoll ist aber
für ihn jetzt der Faktor vielleicht
wirklich nicht notwendig war
muss es seine eigene Entscheidung sein
und wie Daten Druck auf ihn gemacht
wurde das fand ich fand ich einfach
unmöglich ja nur der Herr Kimmich man
muss sich mal überlegen wie viel junge
Menschen sich aufgrund des Druckes
impfen haben lassen die einfach wieder
frei sein wollten und dann kam das
unsägliche 2G ja und da kann sich keiner
frei sprechen da kann sich keiner davon
freisprechen der hier Verantwortung
getragen hat und das ist ja nichts
anderes als eine Impfpflicht durch die
Hintertür und dann kam tatsächlich noch
die Impfpflicht und wie viel haben denn
da dafür gestimmt und zwar tatsächlich
teilweise ohne wirklich ja die sektorale
Impfpflicht ja aber Herr Lauterbach war
z.B ja für die komplette Impfpflicht
aber trotzdem wie viel haben den
Politiker im Bundestag mitgestimmt und
ich bin mir ganz sicher nicht alle waren
ausreichend informiert was ist überhaupt
bedeutet und wenn sie jetzt sagen so
naja also ich konnte nicht um wissen
dass er Impfung Nebenwirkungen hat oder
wie gesagt
das war damals nicht das Hauptthema nein
also ja warum denn nicht genau ich finde
man muss sich immer noch mal dran
erinnern in welcher Situation waren wir
damals ganz viele hatten Angst es gab
auch enorm Druck in der gesamten
Gesellschaft wenn jetzt nicht gehandelt
wird wenn es z.B nicht zu lockdowns
kommt dann verbreitet sich das Virus es
gibt tausende oder hunderttausende tote
wir wussten das damals ja alle noch
nicht deswegen finde ich jetzt auch
etwas einfach wenn man sagt also damals
was ist das falsch gelaufen oder das ist
falsch gelaufen
Punkt sie sprechen ja berechtigte Themen
an ich will die gar nicht hier vom Tisch
wischen die muss man jetzt analysieren
sagen was hätten wir mit heutigen Wissen
anders gemacht und woraus können wir
lernen wenn in der Zukunft wieder so
etwas ist da bin ich völlig bei aber ich
will auch gar alles ist richtig gelaufen
natürlich auch dann die Politik muss ich
hinterfragen unter Lauterbach muss
besonders hinterfragt werden weil
natürlich hat er viele Fehler gemacht
genau man muss man muss man muss gucken
was kann man dann in der Zukunft anders
machen das finde ich es wichtig die
Gesellschaft kann und muss darauf sein
auf jeden Fall nichts vom Tisch wischen
das haben sie auch gerade gesagt man
muss diese Debatte führen auch dass wenn
wir gestern hier an dieser Stelle
versucht mit der Manfred
Lützen ist
wir sehen doch heute das ist doch
totaler Quatsch gewesen ist eine Impfung
wir müssen immer dazwischen dann aber
wirklich Unsinn ist
ein großer Unterschied
sagen Lauterbach kann das einfach mal
sagen es ist ein falsches Wort
verlässt die Sendung glaube ich
es ist sehr schade bleiben Sie bei uns
nein ja so ging das gestern aus diese
Debatte wurde geführt und war dann ganz
schnell auch beendet wobei wir haben
hier in diesem Tisch dann eben nicht
mehr in vollzähliger Besetzung weiter
diskutiert haben diese Debatte geführt
und das wollen wir auch heute tun denn
wir glauben schon es gibt so haben wir
hier in diesem Tisch auf festgestellt
ein Riss in der Gesellschaft und
vielleicht auch den Drang nach einer
neuen nach einer offenen nach einer
transparenten Debattenkultur sie haben
gerade auch das französische Formen ich
ich meine das eine Gesellschaft die wird
hier ist doch total wichtig und ähm also
Meinungen die jetzt sich auf dem Boden
unserer freiheitlichen demokratischen
Grundordnung bewegen ja die wollen wir
doch zunächst mal anhören die wollen wir
nicht abqualifizieren und ich will jetzt
also überhaupt nicht irgendwie den Hobby
Virologen spielen ich fand das sehr
sympathisch was sie eben zum Thema Bauen
gesagt haben das kann ich hier genauso
sagen ich muss sagen ich bin dreimal
geimpfte ich bin sehr dankbar dafür
gewesen ich habe höchsten Respekt vor
allen entscheidungssträgern damals vor
allen Dingen 20 mit so einer unbekannten
Situation zu agieren aber natürlich ist
es doch in der Bevölkerung ganz vieles
Gefühl dass hier irgendwo was schief
gelaufen ist und jetzt wird darüber
diskutiert oder auch nicht warum nehmen
wir nicht ein Forum dafür wie ein
parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss
warum gehen Sie mit Ihren Kollegen in
allen Fraktionen würden sie auch die
heutigen
Regierungsparteien nehmen dürfen den
einiger ihr Koalitionspartner damals war
nicht hin und sagen okay das sind die
Themen die wir wirklich untersuchen Mann
wir können nicht alles untersuchen aber
dass wir wirklich drei vier fünf Themen
untersuchen zum Gegenstand eines
Untersuchungsausschusses der wird nichts
ändern wir haben das präventions Paradox
und alles fein wir hatten
Untersuchungsausschuss beispielsweise zu
Wirecard der hat Wirecard auch nicht
lebendig gemacht der hat auch nicht dazu
geführt dass Leute ihr Geld wieder
bekommen aber der hat manches aufgedeckt
das haben großartige Abgeordnete sich
hier als Aufklärer
betätigt wie der Daniel Bayer ist wie
bei ihnen der Matthias Hauer in der
Fraktion wieder Florian ich fahre jetzt
Staatssekretär daran Sternstunde des
Parlamentarismus gewesen warum nicht
diese parlamentarische Aufklärung wir
haben ja als cdu/csu-fraktion genau das
gefordert das ist dieser Aufklärung
geben muss im Parlament auch in den
zuständigen Fachausschüssen das können
wir nicht im gesamten Bundestag machen
sondern es müssen vor allem dann die
Fachpolitiker übernehmen genau das haben
wir gefordert und da hat leider die
Regierung im Moment gebremst und wir
sind auch bereit unsere selbstkritisch
zu stellen also keiner kann der
politisch Verantwortung getragen hat für
mehrere Jahre oder längeren Zeitraum
sagen ich habe nie einen Fehler gemacht
das ist ja völlig klar mir geht's aber
eher darum dass unser die Fehler muss
man dann analysieren auch benennen und
dann Schlussfolgerung für die Zukunft
ziehen und damit wir uns insgesamt
wollen
in dieser Szene aus der gestrigen
Sendung die sie auch gesehen haben weil
ich das noch mal veranschaulichen
glauben sie wir müssen wieder mehr dazu
zurückkommen auch Brücken zu bauen die
Debatte miteinander zu führen einander
zuzuhören uns aussprechen zu lassen und
vielleicht auch andere Meinungen mal
aushalten sollen ja natürlich muss man
was gestern
wirklich tragisch weil der der
der Teilnehmer von gestern der hat
irgendwann einmal gesagt ich glaube es
ist irgendwie die die
Pflicht eines eines guten
Pflicht sich impfen zu lassen das ist ja
schon Wahnsinn wenn man sowas wie man
sowas von sich gibt und natürlich bin
ich der Meinung dass wir wieder Brücken
bauen müssen und mir widerstrebt sowohl
die eine extreme Seite ja die immer noch
rumrennt und sagt wir brauchen unbedingt
Masken wir brauchen immer noch
Impfpflicht mir widerstrebt ganz brutal
dass immer noch Druck aufgebaut wird und
da reicht einfach ein Blick in die in
die stickoempfehlung hinein wer immer
noch geimpft werden soll ja zum Beispiel
Kinder ab 6 Monate bis zum 5 lebensjahr
bei denen wird nicht explizit die
Impfung empfohlen aber wenn Sie zum
Beispiel vorher krank sind oder aber
wenn in ihrem Umfeld jemand ist der wohl
ist
was bedeutet es im Umkehrschluss man
macht den Eltern quasi eine mordsmäßige
schuld wenn sie das Kind nicht impfen
lassen denn wenn die Oma tatsächlich
komisch bekommt und erkrankt schwer wer
wird denn wohl dann den schuldbeutel auf
sich tragen das Kind und die Eltern sie
sind ja auch selbst Arzt ist das auch
eine Kritik ein bisschen in ihrer
eigenen Zunft das auch die Ärzte gefragt
sind
vollkommen unreflektiert haben die Ärzte
geimpft und ich weiß selbst und den
Vorwurf müssen sich die Leute gefallen
lassen die sind in die Impfzentren
gegangen haben sich zum Teil im
Krankenhaus Urlaub genommen damit sind
Impfzentren arbeiten können weil sie
erhalten Geld verdient haben und haben
völlig unreflektiert diese Impfung
reingedroschen und das darf einfach
nicht mehr sein aber wir waren jetzt
beim Thema wir geben uns die Hände und
wir wir brauchen ja also ich will aber
auch nicht das andere Extrem und dafür
werde ich auch immer wieder geschalten
in verschiedenen Interviews wenn ich
sage bitte nehmt Abstand von dem Wort
Giftspritze das wird auch jetzt wieder
so sein Ich höre es richtig wie das
jetzt wie die wie die aufschreien aber
tatsächlich es ist keine
Giftspritze ja und wenn man so
diskutiert und so argumentiert dann wird
man die Menschen nicht erreichen dann
wird man auch keinen Konsens finden was
ich ankreide ist einmal diese Pflicht
und der Druck der aufgebaut worden ist
und jetzt einfach
dieses wegschauen von diesen Impfschäden
aber irgendwo werden wir uns doch
hoffentlich treffen können und sagen da
muss man aufarbeiten
es ist eine Impfung ja ich sage nach wie
vor das Wort Impfung das ist so
mittlerweile muss ich tatsächlich sagen
ich kann sie nicht mehr empfehlen für
keine mehr bei mir die Risiko Signale
viel zu hoch sind ganz am Anfang habe
ich sie empfohlen bei bei Menschen bis
60 und mit feuerkrankungen ja aber im
empfehlen und empfehlen bedeutet nicht
Druck ausüben und da irgendwo drin muss
man sich wieder treffen aber es darf
nicht sein dass die Kritiker wenn man
einfach nur sagt ich bin der Impfung
stehe ich etwas kritisch gegenüber was
war man dann Nazi
Leugner Corona Leugner impf Ablehner ja
das ist ja vollkommen aus das habe ich
mir zum Beispiel nie zu eigen gemacht
dass sie aber sie kennen doch die
Diskussion
ernst nehmen ich bin da auch völlig bei
ihnen es ist schlecht wenn wir sagen man
ist entweder für das eine extreme für
das andere ich finde man muss die Sorgen
ernst nehmen und in der Tat hätte man am
Anfang der corona-krise und als die
Impfstoffe auf dem Markt kam im
Nachhinein viel stärker auch diese
Sorgen ernst nehmen müssen auch in der
gesamten öffentlichen Debatte das etwas
was Politik aber auch Medien aufarbeiten
müssen und umgekehrt ist es auch völlig
falsch alle zu vertrauen die sich impfen
lassen es gibt ja umgekehrt auch
diejenigen die sagen ja wir wollen wir
gehen auf viel los die fürs impfen
wärmen oder die sich selber impfen
lassen wollen ja auch das ist falsch und
deswegen bin ich genau ihrer Meinung wir
brauchen da Maß und Mitte und am Ende
das ist das was sicher eben auch gesagt
haben mehr Eigenverantwortung und im
Moment sind wir natürlich in der Phase
in der jeder eigenverantwortlich diese
Entscheidung auch treffen muss und im
Nachhinein die die Debatte über eine
Impfpflicht die ist natürlich gerade
jetzt mit heutigen Blick wie aus der
Zeit gefallen
den ganzen Maßnahmen und da spricht man
natürlich nicht von Impfpflicht aber
ohne Impfung ja
kamen weil man sich nicht getraut hat zu
einer richtigen impfpflichten genau
unter Druck setzt und wie viel gibt's
denn jetzt ähm die tatsächlich Schäden
haben die aber angeben ich habe mich nur
impfen lassen weil wo sind denn jetzt
die ganzen Verantwortlichen wo sind denn
die die sich vielleicht mal
entschuldigen weil sie Druck ausgeübt
sind haben wo sind denn die Arbeitgeber
die Druck zu den Mitarbeiter ausgeübt
haben auch heute noch obwohl es keine
Impfpflicht mehr gibt kennen Sie die
aktuellen Regeln der der sticko wie man
sich gerade impfen lassen muss ich kann
jetzt nicht alle Details aus dem Kopf
aber schauen Sie sich mal an es ist es
ist einfach unsinnig es ist wirklich
wirklich unsinnig und ich erwarte von
der STIKO eigentlich erwarte ich schon
lange aber ich erwarte jetzt von der
STIKO dass Sie bitte sich hinhaut und
einfach mal wieder ordentliche und dann
neue Impfempfehlung ausspricht und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir
unabhängige Institute brauchen
nicht unabhängig die ist nicht unbedingt
stellt das Gremium und Sie können mir
nicht erzählen
soll ganz viel wir merken hier an dieser
Stelle es ist ganz viel Transparenz noch
fragt bei diesem Thema
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
nehmen unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
wild kämpft für Sie